willkommen zu einer neuen sendung von
viel okaz diesmal habe ich den stefan
ihr zu gast der stefan ist fahrer aber
nicht nur pfarrer sondern macht auch
noch was ganz anderes
erzähl mir was du sonst noch machst ja
also ich bin von der ekd berufener
ehrenamtlicher prüfer der öffentlichen
hand der freiwilligen selbstkontrolle
der filmwirtschaft freiwillige
selbstkontrolle fsk das kennen wir alle
das sind diese bunten altersfreigabe
siegel auf den dvds auf den videos oder
eben die wir auch die uns im internet
begegnen
ich kenne diese siegel von
computerspielen
da waren die auch häufig daraus aber
heute soll es ja um filme geben und wenn
es um selbstkontrolle geht dann geht es
wohl um filme diese brutal sind mit dem
gespielte themen die rolle spielen oder
so sagen das kann man eigentlich nicht
so sagen also es werden erstmal alle
inhalte die in deutschland
veröffentlicht werden alle bewegten
bilder auf ihre altersfreigabe geprüft
sonst haben sie automatisch die keine
jugendfreigabe und jeder mensch der in
deutschland etwas veröffentlichen möchte
als bewegtes bild muss eigentlich die
filme von der fsk prüfen lassen um sie
zu vertreiben
genau aber es passiert öfters dass wir
filme haben wo wir eben eine sehr hohe
altersfreigabe geben müssen weil das
sehr brutale filme sind oder selten
passiert ist dass wir mal die freigabe
verweigern müssen
da ziehen wir beim entscheidenden thema
verweigert tut man sicherlich manchmal
die freigabe wenn es sehr brutal zugeht
und jetzt würden
wer gerne die frage an dich stellen wenn
es jetzt um das böse geht welchen film
kennst du welcher film ist ihr besonders
erinnerung geblieben wo das böse die
sünde eine besondere rolle gespielt
also mein persönlicher lieblingsfilm ist
apocalypse now aus dem jahre 1979 glaube
ich und da wird eigentlich ein sehr
breiter darstellung diese abwesenheit
von vernunft und dieser wahnsinn des
krieges dargestellt und es gibt diese
figur den waters den kernel der
umgebracht werden soll weil er einfach
offensichtlich den verstand verloren hat
und dort geht es natürlich um das böse
die pointe des filmes ist aber das
wollte kurz eigentlich ja an seinem
auftrag verzweifelt ist also genau es
gibt zu seiner menschlichen motive die
dahinterstehen man kehrt dann irgendwie
auch verstehen dass heißt nicht
gutheißen aber genau kann die motive
letztendlich auch durch den film nähe
gebracht bekommen genau das wäre so eine
frage also wie ich hier viel mit
besonders eindrucksvoll waren in andere
frage wäre wie das böse filmisch und die
sünde besonders inszeniert werden kann
gehen die möglichkeiten der nur der film
hat als medium das böse gesunde
darzustellen wie zb interaktive stehende
bild nicht hatten
also ich würde sagen schon denn es gibt
sozusagen eine mehrdimensionalität im
kino also man hat die bildebene die
tonebene innere und äußere inszenierung
und wenn das alles gut zusammen spielt
dann hat das meines erachtens manchmal
eine größere konsonant oder einen
größeren mehrwert wenn es um das böse
geht also es gibt bilder die unheimlich
hart betörend und verführerisch sind und
dann noch eine passende musik darunter
und eben der bildausschnitt der schnitt
und wie der regisseur eine szene
inszeniert ich finde da
ist manchmal einfach komprimierter als
ein geschriebener text oder ein still
stehendes bild als sie zusammen willen
von ganz verschiedenen aspekten visuell
akustisch genau kann spannung erzeugt
werden wo wir jetzt von diese szenen
sprechen hast du da eine szene vor augen
er oder der erinnerung die ich besonders
beeindruckt hat eine szene eines
bösewichts und einer bösen tat oder
einer spannungsvollen situation bei bin
ist er also es gibt einen film von
michael haneke das weiße band
da wird so eine dorfgeschichte aus einem
dorf kurz vor dem ersten weltkrieg
erzählt und es gibt eine szene wo ein
fahrrad ein dorfpfarrer seine kinder
bestraft die zu spät zum essen kommen
und diese szene hat wirklich eine ganz
interessante inszenierung also vom
bildausschnitt man schaut dem fahrer der
seine kinder bestraft über die schulter
in der einstellung ist der fahrer größer
als die anderen protagonisten die im
raum stehen und es gibt sozusagen eine
noch eine eigene inszenierung der fahrer
verweigert nämlich seiner kompletten
familie und sich selbst als bestrafung
das essen und sagt wir fühlen uns jetzt
alles schlecht ihr beide seid zu spät
gekommen
jetzt wird niemand mehr in ruhe
abendessen können
und dann müssen die kinder aufstehen und
dem vater und der mutter die hand küssen
und als die beiden kinder die zu spät
gekommen sind eben auch anstalten machen
das zu tun sagt der pfarrer ich möchte
von euch nicht berührt werden eure
mutter und ich wir werden heute nacht
eine schlechte nacht haben weil ihr das
was ihr getan habt tut uns mehr wäre als
ja okay dann das ist durchaus der
psychologe hier umgesetzt
denk ich an das böse denke empfehlen
dann kommt mir sofort die figur des
handelns liegt dennoch grandios gespielt
wurden
kannst du diese person dieser figur noch
etwas sein sie wurde ja glaube ich mal
gekürt als die böseste filmfigur ja
niemals möchtet könnt ihr dann noch was
einzig diese figur genau also hannibal
lecter da gibt es ja mehrere
verfilmungen aber ich würde jetzt sagen
ich beziehe mich auf die von jason terry
aus anfang der 90er jahre mit jodie
foster das ist eine paraderolle von
anthony hopkins und die figur wird
eingeführt also cappek begegnet der
clarice starling so heißt die
gegenspielerinnen und sagt ihr dass
diese ganzen messier kategorien oder
maßstäbe die sie versucht an ihn
anzulegen einfach für ihn nichts
bedeuten und auch bei ihm nicht
funktionieren und dann kommt es zu
diesem jahr berühmten dialog einer von
diesen analytikern hat versucht mich zu
analysieren und dann sagt er ich habe
seine leber gegessen mit einer mit einem
wunderbaren chianti und dann macht er
auch so eine schmerz bewegung und ich
glaube das ist sozusagen diese
verhöhnung dieser ja
wissenschaftlichkeit die an ihn angelegt
werden soll die für ihn nichts bedeutet
er hat sich so weit von den anderen
menschen entfernt dass sozusagen das
seine antwort ist und dass man berühmt
ist sehen das ist eine sehr
eindrucksvolle ja viele die mir auch
noch vor augen schwebt
eine letzte frage betrifft die zukunft
des films denn es ist ja jetzt einiges
im wandel dort mann du sagtest vorhin
man kriegt nicht mehr so häufig die
firma als dvd werden häufig schon sofort
ausgestrahlt streaming unterwegs siehst
du da auch die in der zukunft des
internets neue möglichkeiten
filmisch oder serienmäßig dem bösen das
müsstest thematisieren
es gibt ja auch verschiedene fernseher
reihen oder sendungen die also monatlich
immer weiter ausgestrahlt werden diese
story erzählen und mehrere sequenzen
siehst du da neue perspektiven
also was sicherlich neu ist dass es so
eine art medienkonvergenz gibt also dass
man eben auch gut produzierte serien
mittlerweile manchmal im kino zeigt als
sondervorstellung was ich interessant
finde also wenn man jetzt mal auf
comicverfilmung guckt das ist ja so den
trend gibt nicht nur den protagonisten
sondern auch den antagonisten eine
eigene geschichte zu geben
so wird es sein bei der wm um verfilmung
das ist ein spiderman bösewicht und er
bekommt eben seinen eigenen film ich
glaube das ist ein sehr großer
meilenstein dass man aufgehört hat nur
über die protagonisten geschichten zu
erzählen sondern genauso gut kann man
die über die antagonisten auch erzählt
würde wir dazu nähe auf ein was hältst
du von diesem film mit begriff das böse
also ist eine ganz tolle serie extrem
gut produziert wunderschöne
weitwinkelaufnahmen und ich finde diese
figur dass wolter weit das ist
eigentlich ja so eine art luzifer enkel
aus john miltons verlorenen paradies
also der entwickelt ziemlich schnell so
eine art eigenen stolz und ab einem
gewissen punkt ist er so stolz auf das
was er da tut dass er eigentlich nicht
möchte dass sein geschäft oder sein
produkt jemand anderes übernimmt und ich
finde es eine sehr wirklich eine sehr
ausgefeilte und gute interessante
darstellung des bösen
vielen dank der dann für deine
schilderung die expertise zu diesem
spannenden thema
das war es für die heutige
sendungen bis zu einem nächsten kunden